they're stressful and audition's
stressful for every role he's booked
there's a long list of jobs he didn't
get and some of the projects on this
list are pretty major which auditions
did holland not come out of successfully
let's take a look i actually brought
some of my tapes right with me today to
uh to show you guys number one
tom would look very good in a period
piece and we almost had it i actually
auditioned for peaky blinders and i did
not get the part it didn't work out that
time around but the creator of the show
steven knight has expressed that it was
probably just because it was a very
important role for which i was testing
this series has finished its run so our
dreams of holland on the show are done
but knight has also said that the team
behind the peaky blinders film would
love to have him so who knows what's in
store how dare you i've never been so
sold in my life
he could have been a stormtrooper
holland actually got very far in his
star wars audition to play finn the part
that wound up going to john boyega it
was about four or five auditions into
the process when things went a bit
downhill i remember sort of saying like
you're not actually gonna do that right
in the scene he was auditioning for
there was some droid speak that holland
wasn't quite ready for there's no way
this lady is gonna read the robot's
lines opposite me just because that
would be ridiculous the actor got a bit
ridiculous himself as he cracked up
laughing so hard that he couldn't even
get through the take extra awkward since
the woman reading with him was totally
committed to the world they were in she
just was like
suffice to say this rule didn't end up
being tom's but it did leave him free to
do spider-man so not so bad in the end
spider-man absolutely spider-man holland
in the jungle we dig it tom has
auditioned for plenty of huge projects
that required intense auditions but his
read for andy circus's mowgli legend of
the jungle was one of the oddest he'd
ever encountered we do strange things
for auditions but i think your audition
might be the strangest thing holland
took all the right steps in anticipation
of this big audition i prepared my lines
to prepare my scene but you never know
what to expect in the room no director
had ever asked him to do this now do it
as a wolf a stunned holland tried to
think on his feet but the interpretation
well it wound up being a bit surface
level so all i did was this
it wasn't one of the actors best
audition moments but circus was still
able to see just how talented he was and
even called tom's audition brilliant so
no hard feelings there it was a
wonderful experience lovely meeting you
a tough but necessary lesson having
started his career so young tom's
expectations for himself were high and
when his audition for a film called
november criminals came around he saw it
as a potential big break it went really
well and holland was a serious contender
but ultimately ansel elgort booked it
and it came as a serious blow luckily
for holland he had a pretty special
support in his dad it's been so valuable
for me to have someone on my side who i
know is on my side while the actor was
pretty angry about the loss it presented
the perfect opportunity for a life
lesson with dad who explained that you
need a loss so that the win feels like a
win and he almost had the golden ticket
tom holland and timothy chalamet get
mixed up all the time so no surprise
they've been up for some of the same
roles including that of willy wonka and
the wonka origin story at the very end
it was between chalamet and holland but
when it came down to it chalamet was
going to be the one stepping into gene
wilder's shoes while holland found
himself stepping into fred astaire soon
after at the end of the day the fact
that chalamet is a stronger singer gave
him a leg up over holland whose
specialty is as a dancing man or rihanna
depending on the night i used to do a
lot of dancing but that was all
choreographed the name's holland tom
holland before the actor was hunting for
treasure and uncharted holland brought
up the idea of a james bond origin story
project with the sony executives the
idea was problematic to begin with
because the fact that it was a james
bond movie would be a secret until the
very end making marketing a total
nightmare keeping all that in mind sony
didn't go for it but they did propose
the nathan drake roll and uncharted to
the actor and the rest was history for
me this was my go-to movie so to have
the opportunity to make it has been a
real dream come true you never know when
you might do an audition holland
happened to do an impromptu one on the
graham norton show with none other than
tom hanks and it wasn't an easy one
would you like more coffee
hanks asked tallinn to demonstrate an
acting exercise with him and after a
slow start holland gave it his all fully
committing and even improvising his line
a bit coffee please tom hanks give me
some coffee even when put on the spot
holland oppressed
[Applause]
if this was an actual project we have a
feeling he might have booked this one
now this we want to see the australian
jungle set reality show and tom holland
haven't had any formal discussions but
this is one gig holland has said he'd be
all in for i actually would love to do
that although he did have some slight
reservations about potential tasks
explaining i'd find the eating stuff
really difficult and then there was
another issue to consider at least he
was being honest i'm so impatient but i
think i would find some of the people in
there very irritating
he doesn't always hit his mark
okay we know this was a joke but holland
didn't fail to explore every avenue of
the character of peter parker including
a potentially british version of him
oh he is oh all right um
give me a minute let me okay the drama
the absurdity you're tearing me apart
holland had it all covered i feel like i
crushed this no part's mine
wrong comic universe buddy tom holland
is batman well
with great power comes great
responsibility holland was nothing short
of confident that's for sure i have so
much money i'm batman while he doesn't
always book the job holland rarely gives
less than his all even if it winds up
being a bit off the mark sometimes which
role would you like to see tom take on